Let's see. Oh, the Internet. If
you look at my, my net worth,
it's I think it says I'm worth 200 gram
and has a picture of rented showing.
Interesting. I really like it
did for me too. My, my network.
It was a picture of Brendan
Schaub was somebody is fun. Well,
it said Brian and I were brothers or
I'm on Wikipedia for like 10 years ago.
Everybody would say that Pauly shore
thought you would have brothers.
Everybody did. Well, it makes sense dude.
That picture that Brian post of you guys
in the early nineties hilarious dude.
I you had some swag dude.
Good drip, right Jamie?
I was like,
I do.
That's the first thing I know somewhat
like your bro gets fucking fashion. Oh,
you guys both dig down shiny clothes back
then that was like 95 this is why you
and I get along.
He was a [inaudible].
He was a good look at who's cutie
pie to guys. Girls liked him. Shit.
That Liberace front with
the fucking leather jacket.
Those biker jackets are still in. I
still have that jacket and I'm not lying.
I'm fairly muscular. Thank you guys
just got busted. Gerkin no, no. Like,
like a girl. Just pull their dick out.
And by the way, you had never smoked weed.
You had never done any
drugs. People are like, oh,
well the cocaine now we didn't do,
I'd never done blah.
We had a little bit of booze.
Our drug of choice was Brian.
I was, I was 20 I was
heading, I was 28 29 yeah.
We were like, I think it was 27 they're
doing, yeah, you're looking down.
I was 27 you were 28 if I had a time,
if your boy just cracked by day,
I was with the right hands. Right.
Dude, don't ever, I'm losing my dog.
Had QB throws, that bitch ass kick again.
It gets taken down. That's just a dude.
He's just buttering
them up. Ooh, Mitchell.
And riskier Tonto because someone
needs to take that guy to Duke.
Roufus this place.
Teach him how to throw a kick.